in a shanghai supermarket two men get
into a fight while shopping for last
minute supplies
tensions are high since the announcement
of a phased corvette 19 lockdown
the first ever imposed in the chinese
commercial center
from monday those living in the eastern
and southern parts of the city are being
forced to stay home
public transport has been suspended and
mass testing has begun
the lockdown will be lifted on friday
when the same restrictions will be
applied to the other half of the city
earlier this month authorities reassured
the public there would be no mass
shutdown in shanghai but infections of
the highly contagious ompicron variant
continued to rise
we have detected many infections after
several rounds of screening so the
situation we're facing is severe and
complicated
the city has documented more than 10 000
cases in recent weeks
most of those infected have mild
symptoms or none at all but officials
are determined to maintain what they
call a dynamic zero carving strategy
shanghai is china's main financial
center and heavy restrictions are likely
to impact the country's economic growth
the city is home to 25 million people
and is also where the headquarters of
many chinese companies are located
chinese stocks have fallen at the news
the city's shipping port remains open
but some factories including tesla the
electric car manufacturer have
temporarily suspended operations the
biggest impact is on the consumer
confidence uh the income growth has
already collapsed since the start of
2022
and
now uh the unemployment in the city
services sector and the retail sector is
quite widespread
the market confidence is quite low
authorities say food delivery supplies
are adequate and medical facilities will
remain open for those needing urgent
care
but some have complained about the poor
management of lockdown restrictions
on wednesday a shanghai nurse died from
an asthma attack after the emergency
department of her hospital was closed
for disinfection katrina you al jazeera
beijing